bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors en planches confinement est
ce que votre appel a été entendu quelle
forme prend votre action aujourd'hui
alors les actions sont multiples
effectivement il y aura pas de grandes
manifestations dans la rue on le
comprend bien
mais il y à de nombreux endroits des
manifestations plus modestes des appels
devant les directions des motions
déposées auprès des directeurs
on essaye d'être inventif et de
s'adapter à la situation
alors on parle de pédiatres
d'assistantes sociales de
kinésithérapeutes ou encore de
psychomotricien qui travaillent au sein
de l'hôpital
ils ont forcément aujourd'hui d'avoir
été exclus du ségur de la santé alors
nous dans la santé privés non lucratifs
parce que c'est celle là qui touchait
sur notre secteur du privé moi je
représente le privé c'est que ça va plus
loin de ça c'est aussi des aides
soignants des infirmiers et qui
travaillent c'est des gens qui
travaillent dans des grandes fondations
qui ont des services qui seront financés
par le sanitaire donc sur l'hôpital et
d'autres pour des jeux d'écriture et
compagnie sont financés sur le médico
social parce que ce sont d'autres
financeurs et on se retrouve avec des
salariés qui à qualification égale
n'auront pas le même salaire et penser
que pour nous c'est inacceptable
on s'est battu dans le privé pour que
ségur soit aussi étendu sur le privé il
ya une transposer la transposition des
salaires donc prochainement les salariés
du privé toucheront une revalorisation
salariale grâce au ségur qui a été
négocié dans le public
nous on demande que cette transposition
souhaitant duo médico-social qui
regroupa tas de matches effectivement
quel est l'impact aujourd'hui delacre et
sanitaires et dur confinement sur les
salariés que vous représentez que nous
on peut dire aujourd'hui c'est que les
leçons de la première vague n'a pas n'a
pas servi sur ces mâles grand chose
parce qu'on on se retrouve avec les
mêmes problématiques de tenues de
sous-effectif aujourd'hui à moins de
lits dans les hôpitaux
il y en avait au mois de mars l'état
continuer à fermer des lits donc comment
faire on a aussi des salariés qui sont à
bout de souffle parce que l'e tat du
même s'il ya une accalmie l'été a été
dur on a quand même plusieurs collègues
qui sont décédés on a aussi des
collègues qui ont ramené le virus à la
maison et dont les conjoints sont
décédés donc ce n'est pas facile à vivre
les collègues sont vraiment au bout du
rouleau et c'est vrai que le ségur même
si ça répondait pas à toutes les
questions cette revalorisation salariale
avait dû 180 euros en plus de tous les
mois c'était par ya surtout pour les bas
salaires que c'était pour tout le monde
donc tout dans notre secteur des bas
salaires sont en dessous du smig
c'était plus 10% salaire en plus donc ça
a du sens mais en exclure à la santé
nous le créatif ses quarante à cinquante
mille salariés qui vont se retrouver
exclue parce qu'ils sont pas financés
directement par la sécurité au sérieux
parce qu'ils sont financés par les
conseils généraux choses comme ça ça n'a
pas de sens c'est incompréhensible pour
les personnels ils prennent les mêmes
risques
le coc vite quand ils attaquent nos
personnels vont pas voir la feuille de
paye
c'est n'est tous confrontés aux virus et
pour nous c'est inacceptable
d'où la mobilisation d'aujourd'hui qui
est quand même assez fort le personnel
hospitalier qui est encore un peu plus
confrontés au virus quel regard
aujourd'hui ce que vous portez sur les
restrictions en france ces mesures
visent avant tout à empêcher la
saturation des hôpitaux
est-ce que cela vous semble suffisant
est-ce qu'il faut renforcer leur
confiance selon vous
moi je suis je suis pas forcément
compétent pour vous dire les mesures à
prendre de niveau 2 des libertés un peu
dire à l'arrivée présenter ce qu'on peut
dire c'est que il ya effectivement une
deuxième vague
il ya un virus qu'elle a kiss est plus
fort que ce qui avait été prévu sap a
été anticipé par l'état donc
effectivement il faut prendre les
mesures
après est-ce que le confinement est le
meilleur moyen je pense qu'il faut
éviter les contacts entre les personnes
après de la façon dont ces faits là on
se prive de gros problèmes parce que aux
fines et les gens c'est bien autoriser
des enfants aller en cours bachy ils
sont 24 dans sa classe donc je sais pas
comment on va pouvoir les protéger donc
ça manque de cohérence tout ça quand
même
et c'est un peu le sait un peu
ce qu'on entend dans les services parce
que réellement il faut faire quelque
chose parce que les services se
remplissent de plus en plus de patients
mais de la façon dont session se pose
des questions verbe et moins de trains
te dire plus de gens dans les trains
même s'il ya des gens qu'on finit gier
aujourd'hui vous allez dans la ligne 13
de matha vous allez voir
elle est bondé c'est pas normal et on
verra ce que dira le ministre de la
santé clients qui tient donc un point
presse ce soir à 18 heures merci franck
houlgate merci d'avoir permis de réagir
sur notre antenne je rappelle que vous
êtes secrétaire général de l'union
syndicale des syndicats fo sont et
privés